[Música]
estoy caminando por el pasillo y poca
poco a poco veo como las paredes las
paredes se hacen pequeñas mis manos
están sudando mis piernas no responden
como quisiera mi visión se está nublando
literal estoy a punto de desmayarme creo
que estoy a punto de morir les quiero
hacer una pregunta alguna vez han
experimentado un ataque de pánico
alguien aquí ha experimentado un ataque
de pánico levanta tu mano si has
experimentado un ataque de pánico y
cuando digo pánico no estoy diciendo ah
estoy en el baño de la casa de mi novia
y ya no hay papel no puede ser qué voy a
hacer no estoy hablando de ojo deje a mi
bebé en el carro y estoy en el walmart
que hago no nos literal estoy hablando
de un ataque de pánico de esos que te
hace sentir que todo lo que eres se
acaba el día de hoy
pánico y ansiedad son las enfermedades
más contagiosas de nuestro presente y
por muchísimos años yo fui una de esas
tantas víctimas que enfrenta a eso todos
los días por seis años yo viví como
inmigrante ilegal en los eeuu seis años
claves en mi vida de los 16 a los 22
años en los cuales yo tenía sueños años
en los cuales yo tenía anhelos años en
los cuales yo tenía una visión un hambre
todo eso imposible de cumplirse por
situaciones ajenas a mí de hecho durante
esos años me habían invitado a dar una
conferencia ted en mexico pero por mis
limitantes no lo pude llevar a cabo y
creo que si nos ponemos honestos y
vulnerables en nuestro país en nuestro
continente muchos de nosotros somos
víctimas de una rota realidad víctimas
de las circunstancias víctimas de sitio
es que no tiene nada que ver con
nosotros víctimas de las decisiones y la
corrupción de alguien más y si no
tenemos cuidado esas circunstancias y
esos sentimientos pueden dictar el cómo
nos comportamos nos pueden volver
cínicos y apáticos a nuestra comunidad
yo recuerdo en esos momentos de pánico y
de ansiedad en los cuales estaba
enfrentando un desorden alimenticio que
no me dejaba hacer más de una comida al
día iba caminando por un parque cerca de
mi casa y de la nada una persona que
apenas conocía se me acerca y me dice
una frase que hasta el día de hoy si se
ha tatuado en mi mente y en mi corazón
tú te puedes dar cuenta del tamaño de tu
visión viendo el tamaño de tu posición
tú te puedes dar cuenta de los grandes
planes que hay para ti viendo la
oposición que estás enfrentando el día
de hoy y yo sé que eso suena romántico y
suena muy bonito pero a la hora de la
hora cuando todo se descontrola es lo
primero que olvidamos nuestro propósito
nuestra visión nuestros sueños yo creo
que todos aquí hemos sido víctimas de
las circunstancias víctimas de una rota
realidad y si no tenemos cuidado nuestro
corazón se puede llegar a amargar y fue
esa frase que se tatúa en mi corazón y
que en mis momentos más difíciles cambió
mi perspectiva es romántico pero qué
pasaría si como sociedad dejáramos a un
lado una mentalidad de víctima y
adoptamos una mentalidad de servicio en
otras palabras tú no puedes controlar
qué te sucede pero si puedes controlar
cómo afrontas eso que te está sucediendo
tú no puedes cambiar a tu familia tú no
puedes cambiar tu situación tú no puedes
cambiar con tu opinión a las personas
pero si puedes adoptar una contracultura
contracultura y de eso te quiero hablar
del día de hoy de una contra cultura de
cambiar nuestra mentalidad de víctima en
muchas situaciones y empezar a aportar
lo mucho o poco que tenemos en nuestra
mano hacia nuestra comunidad creo que
muchas veces pensamos que somos tan
diferentes y nos enfocamos en todo lo
que nos hace diferentes yo le voy a este
equipo y tú le vas a este otro equipo
yo soy de esta religión y tú eres de una
religión completamente opuesta a la mía
pero si somos honestos como seres
humanos hay más cosas que nos unen que
cosas que nos separan
la realidad es que hay algo que todos
aquí tenemos en común y eso es nuestras
cicatrices todos aquí portamos
cicatrices tal vez físicas cicatrices
que cuentan la historia de esa vez que
te caíste de la bicicleta por primera
vez te acuerdas cuando tu padre le quitó
las llantitas de apoyo a tu bici y
apenas iba saliendo del garage y ya
estabas en el piso cicatrices que
cuentan la historia de cuando no le
hiciste caso a tu mamá y empezaste a
correr en la sala te caíste te pegaste
en la mesa del centro en la mera
orillita y te escala brass te por
primera vez pero hay cicatrices que más
que recordarlas con nostalgia las
recordamos con dolor que hablan de una
de un abuso
que hablan de una relación tóxica que
hablan de algún familiar que te hizo
daño físicamente hay algunos en este
lugar que tal vez tenemos cicatrices
emocionales de aquellas x etiquetas y
apodos que se pronunciaron acerca de ti
en la primaria pero que hasta el día de
hoy te acompañan todos los días al
trabajo
esas palabras esos insultos esas cosas
que te descalifican y yo yo yo recuerdo
enfrentar todo esto y en muchos momentos
también sentir que había cicatrices en
mi espíritu de esas veces que sientes
que en tus restos oraciones topan con el
techo y regresan a tu rota realidad
es difícil pero es la realidad de muchas
personas y creo que todos aquí tenemos
una cicatriz y lejos de aportar nuestras
cicatrices con vergüenza creo que
podemos aportar nuestras cicatrices con
orgullo porque tus cicatrices te hacen
quién eres hoy tus cicatrices cuentan tu
historia y tu historia es una historia
digna de ser contada digna de ser
recordada tu historia puede representar
un oasis para alguien que está en medio
de un desierto tu historia puede
levantar los brazos de alguien que está
por rendirse tu historia es importante y
necesita ser contada de mis peores
momentos y de mis peores situaciones
nacieron grandes sueños porque muchas
veces de la escasez nace la creatividad
de lo que nos falta nos damos cuenta de
una necesidad en mis peores momentos
nació en mí en esos seis años como
inmigrante ilegal nació en mí una pasión
y un amor por la comunidad
una una pasión y un amor pura que di que
es diferente por aquel que nadie quiere
abrazar por aquel con quien nadie se
quiere juntar por el rechazado por esas
personas nació en mi corazón una pasión
y hoy en día después de muchos años de
dificultad habiendo vencido la ansiedad
el pánico los desórdenes alimenticios mi
esposa y yo formamos parte de una
organización que semana tras semana se
encarga de animar inventor e ar a más de
700 jóvenes y adolescentes en ciudad
juárez en diferentes casas y en
diferentes escuelas
hoy en día después de tanta dificultad
mi esposa y yo podemos viajar por muchas
partes de méxico e inclusive del
continente recordándole a las personas
que su situación actual no es su destino
final
y hace algunos meses nació un sueño en
nuestro corazón que si como comunidad en
ciudad juárez méxico
dejáramos de pensar en todo lo que no
tenemos y empezamos a pensar en lo que
si podemos hacer y hace un tiempo mi
suegro quien también es mi jefe quien
también es mi dueño verdad es tan
complicado como suena a trabajar para tu
suegro mi suegro fue a uganda a ver el
trabajo de una organización que se
dedica a rescatar a cientos de miles de
niños desamparados en países en
desarrollo y fue holanda a ser inspirado
por esta por esta organización y vio
todo lo que ellos hacen y cómo rescatan
a estos niños de pobreza extrema y les
dan alimento educación en momentos hasta
ayuda psicológica y regreso hasta ciudad
juárez con un sueño qué pasaría si 300
personas de ciudad juárez
apadrinarán a 300 niños del sur de
nuestro país y no a padre
de una manera de una contribución una
vez cada mucho tiempo sino que en verdad
los apadrinarán desde que son bebés
hasta que cumplan la mayoría de edad y
muchas veces me suelo presentaba este
sueño y la gente se reía como podría una
ciudad como ésta ser tan generosa y me
encantaría presentarte la historia de
una de las niñas que vive en el sur de
nuestro país que no tiene nada porque no
me acompañan
no podemos hacer todo
pero todos podemos hacer algo
y de nuestras situaciones más difíciles
de nuestras cicatrices podemos encontrar
la motivación y la gasolina para no
darnos por vencidos reconociendo que el
tamaño de nuestra visión siente siempre
va a ser igualado por el tamaño de
nuestra oposición que hay en tus manos
que puedes hacer hoy con lo que tienes y
en dónde estás yo estoy convencido de
que a través de cada uno de nosotros
nuestra sociedad puede ser un mejor nos
vemos
[Aplausos]